[Applause]
without further ado
it is with great honor that i introduce
to you ben shapiro
[Applause]
it's awesome to see y'all
so
i did
it's good to be here i did promise my
social media guy that i would actually
take a selfie with all of you so um if
you don't mind
all right
now the millennials will be happy
[Music]
so
first off it is great to be in the great
state of florida one of the best
decisions of my life
i want to thank the ucf administration
the ucf crs young americans foundation
fred and linda allen for making all of
this possible and thanks to dede for the
kind introduction
[Applause]
thanks also for your patience when you
first initiated this event i think most
of you are in preschool
[Music]
so tonight i'm going to be talking about
why people need to stop begging to be
coddled because we now have a society
that demands coddling it's a society
where being coddled is seen as something
good
where a society that coddles you is a
better society now here's the thing
reality is filled with all sorts of
risks the risk that you might try at
something and then you might fail at
something the risk they might make a
mistake and bear the consequences or the
risk that you might run into somebody
who doesn't think like you and this may
hurt your feelings make you feel bad
about yourself make you feel threatened
and more importantly we live in a
society that is now deemed risk to be
off limits risk is seen as a bad thing
now in the past
you really had no choice but to face
down risk because reality demanded that
you face down risk you had to cross
continents to seek your fortune you had
to form families to take care of
children you had to find a community
support to find a support structure you
had to go out into the world and you had
to mitigate risk by creating structures
for yourself that mitigated those risks
or you had to take risks and possibly
reap the benefit and also possibly reap
the whirlwind
now we live in a virtual universe where
we can pretend to make our own realities
we can bubble ourselves off from reality
we can define ourselves subjectively and
insist that everybody around us applaud
carl truman is a really good philosopher
from university of utah he has an
excellent book called the rise in
triumph of the modern self which i think
is maybe the last the most important
book in the last five years
and truman writes that identity our own
personal identity used to be constructed
around your interaction with the world
right there's who you were you're born
you're a baby you have certain innate
characteristics
i have three young children basically
children are small monsters who are
extremely cute right this is god's trick
is you want to take care of them because
they're extremely cute but also they're
terrible little people
every so often they do something like
huh they're so they're so wonderful and
then they start screaming at you and
remind you why they need to be civilized
and that's sort of the point the way
that we create our identities is by
becoming civilized what that word means
typically is that you have to be
acculturated to the culture around you
you have to adjust to reality and who we
were our identities were wrapped up in
our interaction with the reality around
us
now thanks to the prosperity of modern
society and thanks to the fact that we
are guarded from reality by all of these
massive economic structures we've built
for ourselves
we don't have to worry about reality
interacting with us instead we tend to
define ourselves by what is most
authentically us our feelings right how
i feel about me without regard to the
rest of the world is what matters the
most and if reality gets in the way of
that reality is a threat reality is bad
reality threatens my identity it erases
me and so reality has to go away reality
has to change in order to accommodate us
and that's not just true with regard to
identity it's true with regard to group
identity instead of recognizing for
example that in reality inequality is
unfortunately just a part of life that
is just a part of life some of us are
shorter and some of us are taller some
of us are smarter some of us are dumber
that's just the way reality works
and that when it comes to group identity
you could literally draw a line down the
middle of any room in america and you
will have inequalities on one side of
the line versus the other side of the
line if i took a line and i drew it
right down the middle of this room
there'd be income inequality between
this side of the room and that side of
the room there would be iq inequality
between this side of the room and that
side of the room right and those
inequalities sometimes it can be
anything it could be there could be
inequality that's genetic men and women
are on average different heights right
the equality could be cultural korean
culture prizes education more than white
appalachian culture for example it could
be behaviorally driven inequality there
are more black single mothers than white
single mothers right all of these things
create inequality in the aggregate
between groups
okay that's just a reality anywhere you
go on earth this will be true there are
no two groups anywhere on earth that are
going to be identical in every way but
because of that reality because that
reality is ugly and unpleasant
we instead tend to
demand that reality adjust to what we
believe should be the case which is that
inequality should disappear entirely and
all groups should have the same outcome
robin d'angelo the author of white
fragility says quote if we truly believe
that all humans are equal then disparity
in condition can only be the result of
systemic discrimination
which allows us to demand that our
society the richest society and history
bar none thanks originally to our
embrace of risk thanks to our
willingness to undertake risks on behalf
of prosperity we demand that our society
remove risk entirely
and then when bad things happen we
double down
there's no risking and failing society
must have failed
which is actually you think that's
actually an attractive pitch because it
means that nobody actually has to take
responsibility for themselves if you try
and fail it's not your fault it's
society's fault if there is some sort of
inequality out there it might not be
because people need to make different
decisions or adjust to the reality it's
because reality itself needs to be
restructured
and the best news of all is that there
are a group of experts will do it for us
we can simply contract out all of the
risks all of the problems in the world
to a cadre of experts who are going to
tell us exactly what to do
human nature does drive us in this
direction by the way human nature drives
us in the direction of trying to push
away risk by handing over power to
experts this is why authoritarianism is
far more common throughout human history
than freedom freedom is an invention of
the last couple of centuries it really
did not exist on mass until the last
couple of centuries and even then really
only unless
really since the end of the soviet union
has it been sort of the broad movement
of the public across the world but for
the vast majority of human history
literally hundreds of thousands of years
tyranny and privation and bloodshed were
more the way of the world than the
notion of liberty why well because human
nature is loss averse
human beings because we have a lizard
brain our lizard brain evolved in the
jungles we wish to
avoid loss right we don't want to get
hit
so there are a couple of
psychologists social scientists daniel
kahneman and amos tversky you may have
read kahneman's book think fast think
slow
and in the they talk about something
called prospect theory okay what they
find when they when they look at human
behavior is that we have an innate part
of our brain that always seeks to
minimize loss
and so for example i'm going to give you
two scenarios and you guys tell me which
one you want okay so here are the two
scenarios one is
you have a 25 probability of losing six
thousand dollars okay so 75 probability
you lose nothing 25 probability you lose
six six thousand dollars that's scenario
number one scenario number two is that i
flip a coin and depending on which side
of the coin comes up you have a fifty
percent probability of losing two
thousand dollars or a fifty percent
probability of losing four thousand
dollars
so which one of these two options would
you prefer you prefer option number one
twenty-five percent probability of
losing six grand and seventy-five
percent probability of losing nothing or
option two you flip a coin
either way it comes up you lose two
thousand dollars or you lose four
thousand dollars so show of hands who
prefers option number one
okay and who prefers option number two
okay so this is a mental trick nearly
everybody in the room picks option
number one right
okay well here's the thing they're
exactly the same okay on a probabilistic
level your prospective loss there is
exactly the same right a 25 chance of
losing 6 000 means you have an expected
loss
of 1500
a 50 chance of losing either four
thousand or two thousand dollars means
that the expected loss is the same
right the expected loss is going to end
up being the same in this particular
scenario that's because in the former
case
in the former case we think maybe we'll
lose nothing right we're lost overs and
in the latter case there's a three and
four
in the latter case
we are guaranteed that we're gonna lose
something right so we always prefer the
situation where there's a possibility
where we may lose nothing okay the point
here is that human beings because we are
lost averse because we are constantly
seeking to avoid loss
we are
willing to give over power to people who
help us avoid the loss
and you combine this with what's called
the planning fallacy the planning
fallacy being the belief that we can
plan our way out of risk and what we
think is if we can hand it over to the
experts the experts will get rid of all
the risks okay we want to be coddled
human beings have a natural tendency
it's not just the left right thing all
human beings want to be coddled right
this is it's just the truth you have to
train yourself not to want to be coddled
when you don't you end up with what we
have on college campuses for example
with regard to free speech
where we all want to avoid risk right we
want speech codes that protect our egos
from the possibility of words hurting us
in fact we go so far as to redefine
words as violence so that they can never
hurt us
when it comes to the meritocracy the
meritocracy must be rejected too because
what if we fail and then we're blamed
for our own failures
now listen in the meritocracy there's
nothing more meritorious about something
somebody who's smart than somebody who's
stupid right those are inborn qualities
very often
okay but the meritocracy does mean that
there are externalities that benefit
wide swaths of people if smarter people
tend to do well that benefits everybody
because they contribute more in terms of
social capital and social value
because of the products and things that
they are designing right
but if you can get rid of the
meritocracy it makes you feel a hell of
a lot better phoebe cohen the
geosciences professor at williams
college recently said quote this idea of
intellectual debate and rigor as the
pinnacle of intellectualism comes from a
world in which white men dominated
right if if that's your belief that does
ensure that you're never going to feel
too bad about yourself when you fail it
also destroys all of the fundamental
bases for having a civilization
on a broader level this is the message
of critical race theory
according to richard delgado and gene
stefanche are some of the founders of
critical race theory critical race
theory essentially holds four basic
tenets tenant number one is that racism
is ordinary not aberrational it is the
way that society these are direct quotes
this is the usual way society does
business the common everyday experience
of most people of color in this country
second that these systems of oppression
serve quote important purposes both
psychic and material for the dominant
group namely white americans
third that race and races are the
product of social thoughts and relations
so all groupings are essentially
arbitrary but they're created by white
people to harm other people and finally
that minority status quote brings with
it a presumed competence to speak about
race and racism meaning that if you're a
person of color you get to speak about
race and racism and nobody else does
okay when you take that together what
that really means is that all inequality
is inequity
it means any discrepancy can be chalked
up to systemic racism without ever
having to explain how the discrepancy
occurred
you never have to actually point to a
problematic policy in order to explain
why the discrepancy exists you just
point to the discrepancy and this in and
of itself means that all the
institutions are bad
right everything good is fruit of the
poison is free all those institutions
were built by rich white men who were
seeking to enshrine their own racism in
the way the institutions work
right boils down into lesson one's form
crt sounds precisely like ebermex candy
okay and this is a way of reducing risk
in how you think about yourself it's a
way of reducing your mental risk
now here is the thing our version to
risk obviously it applies across the
board it applies to finance we we
outsource nearly all policy to the
federal reserve at this point we have a
cadre of experts who are supposed to
decide how much your dollar is worth and
also keep down unemployment we outsource
all coveted policy to supposed experts
who happen to screw it up six ways from
sunday well maybe funding gain of
function research in wuhan
all these experts fail and that failure
makes us angry because we have been lied
to we've been told we can hand over
everything to the experts and they will
push a magic button and they will fix
everything
but they but they're lying to us that's
not the case
and when they fail they have two
alternatives they can admit it or they
can get us to turn on each other and so
when the experts have promised us they
will mitigate all risks when that
doesn't work instead they blame you they
blame tell you to blame your neighbor
it's your neighbor who's standing in our
way
and so my call today is when you get
beyond the coddling what you realize is
that the coddling in the end is a shield
for people in power to never have to be
answerable if they can promise you that
they will mitigate all your risks even
if they fail they will just blame the
person sitting next to you if you go
along with them you will give them more
power and more power and more power but
you won't lead a fulfilled life
we actually have to re-embrace risk on a
personal level and on a societal level
we have to take the risk of freely
exchanging ideas because that's where
innovation happens we have to take the
risk of being able to invest and reap
the benefits of that risk
we have to take the risks of for example
in our personal relationship in a
personal relationship getting married is
a risk it is foregoing a current benefit
for a future game right you are you are
foreclosing all sorts of other
possibilities because you have chosen to
make a life with this one person that is
a risk marriage is a risk having kids is
a risk you don't know what they're going
to turn out like
right you really don't
and it does very day-to-day on what you
think the trajectory looks like
but the thing is that those risks make
life worth living
the risk might pay off or maybe you fail
and you learn something more deep about
yourself maybe you learn from the
failure and you do better the next time
or maybe it's just that you've
strengthened your own character because
you've made free choices in a free way
which is what makes us human in the end
every decision you make is a risk
the biggest risk of all of course is the
decision to be free and to take
responsibility for your own choices
that's a major risk but if you take that
risk you become a better and a stronger
human being a more contributing human
being a more valuable human being you
feel better about yourself
when we discard risk we discard meaning
when we are coddled we discard our own
ability to be a fully adult human being
and here's the here's the dirty little
secret no matter how much we tried to
discard the risk no matter how much we
try to set up institutions that mitigate
against the risk no matter how many
boxes we draw against the people who sit
next to us in society hoping that this
will mitigate our risk
you can't actually discard risk
it's inevitable because reality entails
risk just as it always did just as when
we were lizard brains wandering in the
jungle there's risk now too and we can
build dams against the risk and the
waters can pile up behind those dams and
then eventually they will blow right
through the dam and when that risk
materializes it'll be a lot bigger and a
lot worse than the tiny risks that we
have been avoiding all the way along
this process
when that dam bursts it destroys
civilizations small risks can be
channeled small risks can be withstood
when you build up entire bulwarks and
edifices of holding back risk and then
the risk materializes it swamps
everything
it's a huge civilizational mistake
reality always wins in the end in fact i
root for reality because when you root
for reality you're rooting for people to
learn how to deal with reality which
again is how we lead fulfilled lives so
we can all do that we can choose to live
free rather than coddled it'll make us
better people more open people more
understanding people
and when we do that i think that not
only will we be saving the country and
saving the civilization we'll be saving
ourselves thanks so much happy to take
your questions
[Applause]
all right can everybody hear me okay can
everybody hear me okay
how about now good okay so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna get to the q a
now there is ashley right here our
treasurer um you're gonna form a line
right behind that green line right there
and we're going to call you up one by
one you're going to stand right here
behind this green line i'll be right
here behind this orange line and we're
going to try to get to as many questions
as possible so please have your question
ready
and just try to be quick and efficient
we want to get through as many people as
possible so um
let's just get started
as always the rule is that if you raise
your hand because you disagree you get
to go to the front
that's always the role
[Music]
if you
so
said if you raised your hand and if you
disagreed happy birthday over there to
the front
ask your questions first
oh and quick correction because i'm bad
at math the first hypothetical should
have been twelve thousand bucks versus
zero not six thousand bucks versus zero
sorry go ahead
hi ben my name is orlando
uh you can't notice but my parents are
both cuban i'm a latino american first
generation
um so this is a very important
topic for me um
there's no real
right side to the hispanic or spanish
media
and i wanted to know why has the right
avoided this
or have hasn't tackled this situation
because
as you know the latino community is the
biggest minority group in these upcoming
elections
uh i wanted to know if you
or were you with the daily wire or any
right-sided media
is going to tackle this situation for
the upcoming elections
uh yokiro i mean i want to so this is so
i'm
i mean i'm actively taking spanish
lessons like three times a week and
working on it because i think it's
really important actually for for people
who are on the right side of the aisle
to to
speak languages that are not english i
don't think conservatism is only the
language of english so first of all
congratulations on being with tinks or
latinx or whatever nonsense or
[Music]
yeah i know it's whenever people use
that kind of stuff i'm always like i
mean my hebrew is much better than my
than my spanish but uh but like the
notion that you can take a gendered
language and make it non-gendered by by
just force of law is insane um the the
answer is yes we i've actually have i
was talking actively with a person who's
a spanish-speaking free-market economist
about doing some stuff for us i really
want to make a move into this market i
really do want to make a move into this
market i think it's really really
important
[Applause]
uh first things first i want to thank
you so much for coming here today you
were actually one of my inspirations
from going from completely left to uh
moderate and centrist and running
towards uh conservatism okay my question
[Applause]
uh my question for you is this how is it
that people on the left can point can
pull out these hypocrisies i.e
guns bad police bad but uh
only cops can have guns a good thing
and when you're able to call them on
their hypocrisy how is it that they can
basically run along with that hypocrisy
and continue on and continue to try to
shut us down yeah i mean it's it's a
great question the internal
contradictions in a lot of left-wing
logic uh are pretty glaring i mean that
that is a pretty obvious one that you
mentioned the notion that cops are bad
cops with guns are bad they're it's a
racist superstructure also the only
people who should have guns are bad
racist cops um that's that's a it's a
it's a very weird take um the answer is
that it makes it very difficult to have
an honest conversation when people are
willing to entertain these two
possibilities at the exact same time
without actually mentioning that they're
mutually exclusive and it does make you
suspect the truth is not actually a
value if somebody is is making those
points and so i think one of the great
frustrations that we have on the right
is that for many people on the left
right now i do distinguish your liberals
from people who are leftists right make
this
there's a reason we sell leftists to a
mug but we don't have a tumbler but we
don't have a liberal tears tumbler right
there the reason is because liberals are
people who disagree with me on politics
but don't want to shut me down uh people
who are on the left like hard left do
want to shut me down people who are left
wing and who are interested only in the
use of political tools in order to
achieve their agenda without regard to
consistency of argumentation can't be
argued with and frankly you're wasting
your time there's only i've said this a
thousand times to people but when you
have a conversation or a discussion with
somebody you really do have to determine
in advance what's the purpose of the
conversation this is true in in almost
every single case right whether you're
talking with a friend or a spouse or
whether you're talking with somebody on
the issue of politics you have to
determine what's the end goal are you
talking to an audience right and the
conversation you're having with this
person is really directed out here or
are you trying to convince this person
in which case you have to determine
whether they're having an honest
conversation right so if they refuse to
even acknowledge the logic of the kind
of position you're talking about then
it's a waste of time you really should
move on with your life
thanks
[Applause]
so in 2019 you went on joe rogan's
podcast and you had a a religious
conversation with him you're asked about
your view on jesus christ and you said
jesus was a jewish rebel who tried to
lead a revolt against the romans was
killed for his trouble my question is um
jesus said give to caesar's what is
caesar's and the roman governor even
said at first that he was not guilty of
any crime so given all of this how can
you argue that he tried to lead a revolt
against the romans right so i mean
you're assuming so i said from the
jewish perspective right i'm not arguing
from the christian perspective i presume
that nearly everyone in this room knows
the new testament better than i do uh so
uh as you know the jewish perspective on
jude on jesus is better than most people
who are christian right because it's a
jewish perspective on jesus so the
jewish perspective on jesus
does not accept the the historicity of
the gospels if it did then we'd all be
christian right so the the the jewish
perspective on jesus is that like many
people at the time and this was true
throughout that entire period there are
a lot of jews who are attempting to lead
political revolts against the romans the
jewish definition of the messiah is very
different from the christian definition
of the messiah the christian definition
of of the messiah in the form of jesus
uh is of course the unification of god
and man right this this doesn't exist in
the in the notion of jewish philosophy
in jewish philosophy the messiah is a
person who accomplishes particular goals
according to maimonides the gathering of
the exiles the re-establishment of the
vivid kingdom uh the the
re-establishment of jewish sovereignty
in the land of israel right so it from a
jewish perspective if someone was trying
to be the messiah they would be a
political figure okay when i said that
he was killed for the trouble that was
not demeaning of him i assume that if i
had been living at the time i also would
have been attempting to lead revolts
against the romans just like half the
jews were right this is why a temple was
destroyed this is why jews were put into
exile several times so that was not a
smear against jesus as a jew it's just a
recognition that jews don't believe in
jesus as divine figure uh and if we did
then we'd be christian
well then i probably would have changed
the phraseology of that because then
again if that was the case then he would
have been going against jewish law since
say that would have made him a political
figure then he would have been going
against jewish law not roman laws well
he wouldn't know a leading revolt
against the roman wouldn't be going
against jewish law either so the i mean
we want to get into like a long you know
complex debate over what you think about
the the you know historicity and the and
the take on judaism that's in the
gospels that's a pretty long
conversation honestly it's really
interesting and it's and it's kind of
fascinating but
under jewish law even if you read the
new testament jesus
jesus claims aren't punishable under
jewish law by death actually if you if
you look at like the talmud for example
what jesus was claiming to be even if
somebody came along and said i'm a
messianic figure i am the son of god
right that that's not actually
that the punishment is typically not
turning them over to the romans to be
killed so there's it's there's all sorts
of from a jewish perspective historical
problems again i repeat i'm not telling
christians don't go to church i'm not
telling christians not to believe i'm
just telling you what jews believe about
jesus which is by definition going to be
different than when christians believe
about jesus
[Applause]
hello ben i'm very nice seeing you today
and dreams come true
and
my question is um do you think parents
across the country will be able to
defeat school boards and eventually
change the system of education so the
answer is it depends on the school board
and depends on the location so i so yes
i mean the answer is yes i think that
parents if they gather together the good
news is nobody votes in local school
board elections so it doesn't take that
many votes to overturn a local election
at a school board right i mean it's like
the immediate family of the school board
members uh and and whoever the teachers
union can turn out from the homeless
shelter that day that's
right that's that's who votes in school
board elections so if you can turn out
more people than that presumably you can
get people tossed off the school board
and i think that a lot of people are now
awake to what their kids are being
taught i think a lot of parents just
like with colleges i think they're a lot
of alum who don't even bother to look at
what colleges are teaching they just
sign a check to the school that they
that they went to and then when they're
told they're like oh man maybe i
shouldn't assign a check to you know
this particular university for a lot of
parents they just say okay well i went
to public school and my parents went to
public school my kids are going to
public school what could be so bad and
then when they finally see what exactly
their kids are being taught they say oh
that's terrible and then they get really
involved like you're seeing in loudoun
county which again is a very blue county
up in virginia
so i do think that there is a
possibility of revolt i think it's much
strong
first of all i don't think it's totally
necessary in every place in the country
there are some school boards that are
not doing this but yes i think there is
that possibility and
let's just put it this way the good news
is they're still in out meaning that if
these public schools continue to do this
they're just going to drive people out
of the public schools entirely which to
my mind is not a bad solution i'm
perfectly happy with tens of millions of
children being taken out of public
schools and being put into parochial
schools private schools are homeschooled
i think it's a really good solution
um hello it's nice to get an opportunity
to talk to you ben
i wanted to ask about um vaccines and i
wanted to ask
do you think forms of risk aversion for
society as a whole
as in mandating the vaccine and unless
you have a medical exemption or
religious exemption do you think a
vaccine mandate would be good
in terms of risk aversion for society
overall so i think that the the big
problem is when risk aversion turns into
complete
risk denial so when you hear dr fauci
for example say that if you get sick i
don't even want you getting sick right
nobody even gets sick from coven like no
scientists worth of salt at this point
is pretending that we are going to wipe
cove it off the face of the earth it's
just not going to happen literally
hundreds of millions of people have had
it at this point there will be hundreds
of millions people who have in the
future it's going to become endemic
everybody understands this so then the
question becomes what is the purpose of
a mandate right is the mandate going to
be effective is it violation of liberty
you don't man there's a difference
between the kind of vaccines that
typically we have mandated and the
covered vaccine so for example the polio
vaccine or mmr right or dtap right these
are all vaccines that are very typically
mandated at the state level for young
kids these are childhood diseases the
the vaccine itself is highly effective
and if you wipe it out at the childhood
level it typically is not endemic in the
population cova is not a childhood
disease coveted is in everybody disease
but mostly it's an adult disease it's
almost not a childhood disease right
kids who are getting it are not dying
the grand total number of kids across
this entire pandemic in the united
states who have died according to dr
marti mccarry from johns hopkins
university grand total of kids who have
died for a year and a half out of a
sub-population below the age of 19 of
some 73 million americans
10 to 20 healthy children have died of
covet the entire pandemic that's out of
700 thousand people who died in the
united states so it's not a childhood
disease basically you're vaccinating
kids to protect adults we don't have
this this doesn't exist with any other
mandatory vaccine for example to
vaccinate kids to protect adults when it
comes to adults we generally don't have
mandatory vaccines unless you are in a
particular area of american life right
you don't have to take a measles vaccine
in order to work at the grocery store
you don't have to say like this is this
is not a thing when you sign up for
employment typically they don't ask you
for your immunization record that's
something that you ask when you go to
public school or if you're in the army
or maybe you're in the healthcare
profession but it's like very specific
places and very specific times the
notion of widespread vaccine mandates
again these vaccines are extreme thank
god they're extremely protective against
hospitalization and death they're not
nearly as protective against infection
which is fine frankly like nobody cares
how many people get a cold or get a mild
flu over the course of a year i'm not
sure why anybody cares if you get a mild
case of coved after having been
vaccinated and if you choose not to be
vaccinated because you're a young person
and you feel that your health factors
are don't put you at severe risk and you
say okay my chances of dying from kovid
as a young person are say one in ten
thousand and my chances of getting a bad
effect from the vaccine are say
one in eleven thousand so you know hell
i'll chance and i'll go for the natural
immunity whatever
do i think that the government should
force that on you no and by the way i
don't think it would be not necessary in
the case of something like smallpox when
people made that comparison which is
idiotic because smallpox killed a third
of the people who got it
if if covet killed a third of the people
got it you wouldn't have to convince
anybody to get the vaccine in fact there
is one sub-population of the of the
country that has nearly entirely got the
vaccine namely the people who die from
it everybody above the age of 65. if you
look if you look in the state of florida
pretty much everybody who's above the
age of 70 has gotten the vaccine
and that's because people above the age
of 70 are are much more likely to die
it's like 5 out of 100 is the death rate
the ifr uh on so do i think that
mandates are effective here no i think
they're not only ineffective i think
that they are driving a wedge in society
i think they're hardening people's
position on this thing
i think the mandates are not taking into
account natural immunity which is insane
considering that every study available
shows the natural immunity is far more
durable than vaccine immunity to this
point in time we still don't know how
many boosters it will take to match
natural immunity for example right we're
going to go into round number three we
don't know that it'll be around number
four none of this is to say that people
shouldn't get the vaccine i took the
vaccine my wife took the vaccine my
parents took the vaccine what it is to
say is that you have to make that
assessment on an individualized level
and if you choose to get vaccinated
which i do encourage for people
particularly who are above the age of
say 30
and i think that it's probably a good
idea if you're above the age of 20. i
think one dose is probably a good idea
if you're above the age of 12 and i
think that if you're below the age of 12
i have nothing to say to you if you if
that's the if that's the
you know
that's my that's my personal advice
based on my speaking with with
epidemiologists and doctors about this
sort of stuff but if you choose not to
get it that's on you
and then we all move on with our lives
literally the moment that everybody had
the ability to get the vaccine this
pandemic was over from a public policy
perspective and the insanity of telling
everybody they have to continue masking
up until the end of time we're going to
mandate a business you have to fire
employees because they're not they're
not vaccinated
this is when i talk about risk aversion
to the point of being completely in
denial of full-scale reality i'm talking
about the people who won't go back to
work after being triple daxed
so i would want to ask a quick follow-up
question then do you think uh people you
said that people aren't like at risk
themselves that are healthy but do you
think that
allowing other them to infect other
people after they have coven should they
not get vaccinated to prevent infecting
others like those who could be
immunocompromised or right so so in
terms of so in terms of herd immunity so
there really hasn't been achieve
achieved herd immunity nearly any place
on earth except maybe sweden where they
allowed it to run
through
excuse me a lot of swallows of the
population pretty early
i know you're all dying now i know
i've killed you all this is the stand
the uh i'm i'm very much pro the idea of
herd immunity i just don't think that it
is going to be achieved with this
disease particularly given the fact that
we thought that we were close to herd
immunity than delta hit and it would
wipe through the population the bottom
line is again
given the fact that natural immunity
what i've said to everybody is this
you're going to get covet immunity it is
your choice how you choose to do so do
you choose to do so by getting coveted
or do you choose to do so by getting a
vaccine those are there is no third
choice where you just avoid covet
entirely and if you're immunocompromised
the fact is that you should be taking
special precautions in any day and age
and people who are immunocompromised do
if you're seriously immuno if you're on
chemotherapy like the school that we go
to my kids go to there's a teacher there
who's on chemo and she's very worried
about the kids not being masked in class
for example and the answer to that is if
you've ever met a child a child is a
germ machine all they do all day is
generate snot that's just what they do
and because all they do is generate
germs if you've got if you're on if
you're taking chemotherapy you probably
should be wearing an n95 anyway
right if you're deeply worried right now
wear an n95 and leave everybody else
alone
thanks
hi
hi uh i'm so honored to uh be talking to
you because i've been like obsessively
watching your videos since i was 12.
i've been obsessed with politics since i
could like listen to things and um i
guess to make a long story short i
decided to pursue politics after i was
canceled on like vice and daily mail and
like all these different websites
because i'm really badly saying the
national anthem at cpac so um
i i haven't had a lot of like traction
since then so what advice do you have
for somebody that's going into politics
to actually build a following because
all of my press was negative so i don't
have any fans
well as someone who's had their their
fair share of negative press um
uh i will say that that the thing that
you have to find is sort of
the market opening what is the market
seeking that you can provide and this is
true for everybody in every field this
is not just true in politics you need to
find the confluence of things that you
are good at that you enjoy doing and
that other people want you to do right
people have a very difficult time
fulfilling all three of these conditions
if you fill all three of these
conditions you will be successful and
famous and rich
right find the stuff that you're good at
that other people want you to do and
that you're actually good at because
what most people find is this the thing
that they like to do but they're not
very good at nobody wants them to do
right and that's how you end up with a
low income uh or or another way to get a
low income is you do something that
people would like you to do but you do
it badly or or you hate doing it so you
have to sort of figure out what it is
that you want to do and then you have to
provide the market opening so in
journalism or political journalism the
first thing i say to young people is you
have to provide information first so
everybody listen i have a great job i
get to give my opinions for a living
i was basically working in near
anonymity from the time i started
writing my syndicated column at 17
kind of until i did a the the piers
morgan interview in 2012 right so that
was that's a long period of time those a
decade basically in the wilderness
nearly writing for free so number one
expect to make no money and write for
free this is true by the way again for
pretty much every profession you have to
work your way up from the bottom you
have to take jobs that you're not going
to like and then you're going to learn
how to do a business and you'll be good
at it right but at the beginning you
don't know anything because why would
you know anything you're literally just
starting so you have to do a lot of work
for free you have to find a way to
provide people with something that
they're not being provided so if you're
doing political journalism information
and particularly researching things on
the ground where other people don't have
that information so this is why i've
said to college students what my mentor
andrew breitbart once said which is if
you have a cell phone you're now a
journalist right you get to you get to
point that cell phone at things and
there are a lot of newsworthy things
happening on campus so that's where i
would start as far as the negative press
in the past
the good news is that everybody has an
attention span of a nap
nobody cares like we spend so much time
thinking about what people think of us
it never occurs to us that nobody does
like really like it's amazing you know
for me i so i trend on twitter
approximately every 18 days
that that's not actually an exaggeration
it's pretty much every 18 days on the
dot and when i trend i feel pretty good
about it because it means there's
another two and a half weeks where i
won't so it's
but when i trend it feels crappy right
because normally they're trending me for
something incredibly stupid i i will say
that i haven't trended for something
that i actually regretted saying for for
a while it's usually just something
where i'm like i feel like that was
obvious i'm not sure why i'm trending uh
and and when i trend really bad for for
several days it's usually because i said
something hilarious or that i at least
find funny enough that i'm willing to
take the hit i mean that rap thing was
hysterical i don't care what anybody
says that that bit is amazing if you
watch it
everybody should go back and watch the
original 15-minute monologue on it not
that not just me reading the lyrics the
15-minute monologue which is one of the
best things i've ever done on the show
um
oh i appreciate that uh
it does slap much harder than cardi b's
version uh the
but
but bottom line is find something that
you can provide to the market that
nobody else can do it well find out
whether you like it or not and then
you'll be good to go
thank you
[Applause]
oh i'm sorry
hello ben i love the shout out to carl
truman um
his work critiquing career theory and
gender theory is great so i love how you
point that out my question is pertaining
to gender theory so it seems like it's
become very prevalent in academia and
even in in
conservative circles per se the belief
that gender and sex are dualistically
split and one's identity has nothing to
do with their autonomy i mean they're
they're biology
yeah so i see a lot of conservatives
push back against critical theory being
taught in schools right but where is the
conservative where's the large
conservative pushback against queer and
gender theory since it seems like some
conservatives are fine with saying that
gender is a whole linguistic performance
as butler would say or it's completely a
social construct so this is what i do
talk about this in my last book plug the
authoritarian moment um
in this book i talk about the tendency
for conservatives to basically give an
inch and then be surprised when a mile
is taken right conservatives want to be
nice we do we like to humor people we
actually prefer not all of us right some
of us are jerks but but a lot of us like
to you know give people what they want
be nice and interpersonal relationships
and so when someone says i want you to
call me by this thing that is not
actually objectively correct we'll kind
of go all right you know fair enough
whatever like does it just bother me is
it really a big deal and the answer is
yes when you sacrifice truth on the
altar of being kind you have sacrificed
truth on the altar of being kind and
it's difficult to get back truth once
you've killed it
and this is and so i mean i think that
any conservative who pretends that it
doesn't matter for example whether a
biological male is called he or she
i i don't know how you can call yourself
a conservative or even really a
classical liberal in that sense i mean
the fact is that there have to be
certain objective truths that are
objectively verifiable in the world and
we have to use language in a way that we
commonly understand and that conveys
information otherwise we're just
jabbering at each other like animals and
that's that's not that's not good now as
i've said many times if i'm in a room
with a transgender person we're having
dinner together and this has happened
and the person wants me to call them by
their pronouns in private i'm happy to
call them whatever they want if they
want to call me napoleon bonaparte i'll
do it i don't care it doesn't matter to
me but in a public setting i'm not going
to sacrifice the validity of truth on
the altar of niceness i'm not going to
do it right if i'm if i'm on stage with
a person who is a transgender person i
will say that they are biologically male
if they are biologically male and i will
call them by pronouns that match their
biology because this is what pronouns
are designed to do they're not meant to
they're not designed in order to
describe your subjective feeling about
yourself which is unverifiable by any
objective metric right otherwise we
cannot have a language we cannot have a
conversation so yeah i'm i object
strenuously to conservatives who who
think that somehow these are side
battles they don't matter when you just
focus on tax cuts like i'm sorry but if
if if the distinction between male and
female which is perhaps the most
biologically ingrained distinction in
mammalian biology not just humans
mammals right sexual dichotomy is a
thing in mammals it is end of story it
is the basis for all reproduction
if if you cannot
state that and just state that clearly
then i'm not sure exactly what kind of
civilization you think you're defending
[Applause]
hey how are you so uh obviously the uh
the cancel mob is quite a uh force to be
reckoned with and i'm sure you have had
your fair share of experiences with them
so what would your advice be to someone
who is who has a platform is
conservative necessarily doesn't deal
with politics directly
but um what would you give
as far as advice goes what would you say
to someone who could potentially be a
target in the future
uh so i mean so a couple of things one i
i recommend to all of you get off social
media now right do not post anything if
you wish to have a future
come with me if you want to live don't
put it on
don't put it on social media think
whether it is worth the fight right like
so look i'm i started writing column at
17 which means all of my dumb thoughts
from the time i was 17 were hitting the
internet i would say that
85 of the things that i regret having
said happen between the ages of like 17
and 21.
right really like virtually everything
that i've said publicly that i think man
that was a dumb thing to say happened
when i was very young because this is
when you're developing thoughts when you
do it out loud when you're in permanent
form it's a problem for you and we live
in an unforgiving graceless paganistic
society that does not allow for people
to make mistakes and then walk them back
right which i object to in total i think
it's terrible i think it's awful it's
the reason why i may be the only
columnist in public life who literally
has a list on my website of all the
controversial things that i've said
explaining whether i think that i was
wrong whether i think i was stupid or
whether i was right and you just don't
like what i'm saying right like it's a
very long list because i've written
probably not probably i know i have
written millions and millions of words
over the course of the last decade and a
half uh or a couple of decades at this
point so the
so that's number one right if you don't
want something memorialized don't put it
out there number two you don't have to
be canceled if you don't want to be
canceled and what i mean by this is that
you have to take into account you know
where you're working obviously if you're
working a major corporation they fire
you that's a cancellation but what i
mean is in the culture
because it's an unforgiving culture the
one thing we can learn from trump is
that you never have to apologize and
everything will be fine
right this is the it really was like
[Applause]
now for the sake of society i'd like to
go back to a culture where you can
apologize for being a boorish jackass
and everything's okay right but as long
as we're not going to a pot we're not
going to forgive anybody and then you
apologize we're gonna step on your
throat then better to be trump than the
guy who's apologizing and gets the boot
on his throat so well so what that means
is that walking toward the fire is
actually useful very often the
cancellation is over nothing and one of
the things we're trying to do at daily
wire is prove to people that there is a
place for people who get booted out
right this is what we did with gina
carano right for example right this is
what we did just now with allison
williams if you get booted for for not
really doing anything wrong then we want
to show people that your life is not
only not over there's a whole other side
of the market over here just for you
andrew breitbart used to say walk
towards the fire and i think that's a
pretty good strategy
one more question
would i be able to get you right here
right now to pledge your undying
allegiance to matt walsh's sweet baby
gang
no okay
[Applause]
hi ben how are you tonight
doing okay how are you
wonderful thank you
so i'm sure you're very aware of the
infiltration of these leftist ideologies
in the academic setting
and i was wondering if you or what's
your best advice for students like us
in discerning between information and
theories that are based on valid and
reliable research
and ideologies that are more kind of
just being pushed towards us because
they want us to believe those
so it is actually sort of important to
learn how to read statistics it's sort
of important to learn how to read
studies and you have to spend some time
with that stuff and familiarize yourself
with that stuff because very often
studies for example just refuse to
mention confounds right they'll have a
very simplistic analysis of
a happens and then b happens and there's
a correlation between a and b therefore
a cos b for example that's the obvious
one but usually c cos b right usually
some extraneous factor uh or it could be
that the level of significance that
they're playing with the significance
levels in a particular study in order to
achieve significance right or they're
leaving out factors like
here's the thing about academic
publishing so this is a little bit of
truth but in academic publishing you
only get published if you come up with
significant results so if you spend a
year of your life coming up with the
study and the result is insignificant
you now have a choice you neither file
draw it right you just get rid of the
study and say oh well didn't come out
the way i wanted or you can actually
with the numbers a little bit and
come up with a level of significance
where now you've come up with a brand
new study and boom now you're in the
academic journal uh peer review is not
actually a wonderfully
thought out process it doesn't work all
that well particularly in the social
sciences so
here's what i would say
your first question here this should be
a good place to start
if there is a so because typically we're
speaking about social science here i
assume right if you're if you're so if
you're if there's a social science study
and it seems to be a complete rejection
of all conventional wisdom developed
over millennia you should think very
seriously about whether it's
and the reason i say this is because
accepted wisdom over the course of
centuries is in fact a feedback loop
right it's been tested and it's been
tried over the course of time it has
much more durability than whatever study
somebody came up with in the last 37
seconds or so this is a major
distinction that gk chesterton draws
between conservatives and liberals it's
the best way to explain it so i'll just
use his language right the basic idea is
if you have two people and they're
walking across a field and they come
across a fence in the middle of the
field they have no idea why the fence is
there the person who is on the left will
look at the fence and say i see no
reason why this fence is here let's pry
it up and move on and the person on the
right will say i'm not going to let you
pry up that fence unless you explain to
me why the fence is there you need to
first figure out why the fence is there
and why it had been put there in the
first place and then maybe we'll talk
about whether we need to remove the
fence well there's a tendency in social
sciences to say okay so we've had
generations to know for example that two
parent families do much better than one
parent families in terms of the the
outcomes of their kids in terms of crime
in terms of poverty in terms of all the
rest and then there will be a study and
it'll be seen to contradict all of this
you should think to yourself okay i
really need to take a second look at the
study i really need to take a second
look at this and see if there's there's
a misread or a confound how large the
statistical sample is because when you
have really durable evidence over the
course of a very long period of time
that a thing is true you can't just
ignore that wisdom in favor of okay a
couple of professors from a second rate
university wrote a paper and then it was
published in some obscure journal
somewhere and is now being cited on nbc
think
thanks
[Applause]
little hebrew lingo for you all there
yeah
it's just how jews say hello
correct
and also we were planning the banking
structure
after the media discussion of course
it's an honor to meet you and thank you
so much for coming out and if you're
ever in the area i'd love to have your
first chavez i appreciate it more juice
stuff okay um so my question is is that
over the past four years we have seen
the left become radical in ways that we
didn't think was possible it is i would
say that it's completely un-american to
tolerate political violence against your
opponent and we've seen things from
advocating for milk shaking um stephen
crowder did a um an undercover event
where somebody handed i think it was a
producer of his like a it was a knife or
a pic that's the university target
and
i always believe that the left and the
right want the same thing we just go in
a different way where the right goes a
bottom up from the people going all the
way up to where the left goes a um top
bottom where
um you start from government
and it goes down to the people that's
supposed to be the the hand that drives
so with what we're seeing the tolerance
for all this violence for looting for
rioting and all of these things where
they want to remove our rights
re-educate and do all these awful things
to us
is i i want to still continue like to
extend a hand i like having conversation
with leftists but it's become more
difficult because there are times where
i fear for my safety i've been
surrounded by people and it's not a
comfortable feeling yeah i mean so what
what do we do where do we go from here
well i mean for me i just pay security
to surround me at all times but if
you're
but
if you if that's not your thing
then you know i then look like i said
you have to sort of assess whether the
conversation is worthwhile or not
unfortunately that is the reality i'm
also not going to pretend that there i
mean look there are people on the right
who have been very casual in their use
of terminology about violence now i will
say it i think it is much more prevalent
on the left i think it is much more
institutions of power on the left i
think that you saw an entire left-wing
institutional infrastructure last year
support full-scale riots in many
american cities uh that i i haven't seen
that sort of institutional support for
violence on the right i just i i don't
think it exists on the right in the same
way
with that said i also i also take i'm
gonna take issue with the basic idea i
also used to think i think that the the
left and the right wanted the same thing
they just got there in different ways i
don't think that's actually true i think
that they want very different things
right now i think that the wright would
like a a more freedom-based society in
which people leave each other alone and
i think the left would like a society in
which justice is established at the cost
of people's rights and if that has to be
done top down then it has to be done top
down and it has to be done bottom up it
has to be done bottom up so
that's that's a dangerous situation to
be in the left has gotten much more
radical over the past few years there's
no question about it
so i guess what i'm like trying to ask
is though where do we go from here and i
don't really agree with that premise
anymore that we want the same thing but
it's something that i used to yeah i
mean so i i think where we go from here
is what i've said is the future of the
country doesn't lie with the right and
it doesn't lie with the left it lies
with all the people in the middle which
side you're going to take right you're
going to have to decide are you going to
let's say that you're a center-left
person who generally agrees with the far
left on tax policy but you disagree with
how they shut down free speech and you
disagree with the rioting in the streets
and disagree with you fund the police
and all of that so now here's your
choice are you going to go along with
the left-wing policy agenda at the
expense of the rights or are you going
to say to the left-wing listen we may
agree with you and maybe we'll get to
where you're going slower
but we have to respect the individual
rights if the second thing happens the
country survives if the first thing
happens we're in serious serious trouble
right this is why i have a lot of
respect for people who i disagree with
politically and i i as people know who
watch my show on the sunday special i
have people who disagree with me
literally all the time i mean it happens
all the time and those people i have a
lot of respect for right larry wilmore
from comedy central for example formerly
of comedy central or barry weiss right i
mean like they're a bunch like barry
weiss and i don't agree on anything
except maybe israel and free speech
right individual rise we disagree on on
lgbt issues we disagree on tax policy we
disagree on social safety social social
welfare policy right all that stuff but
we definitely agree on the fundamental
principle that underlies the country
which is that we have to decide all this
stuff by open conversation those are the
people who are going to decide it barry
earns more followers than the new york
times and we're in good shape the
opposite and we have a problem
we're going to do
two more questions
and then we'll wrap it up
okay
oh sorry
okay hi ben my question cons sorry i'm a
little sick not covet i got tested okay
i got tested i got dozen okay my
question is it's fine i'm vaccinated i
don't care but go ahead
pfizer or modernity pfizer i mean
the gold standard
microchipped in 2012 the red line
documents were exposed at the israeli
government displaying that the
government calculated the exact caloric
intake palestinians needed in order to
survive the israeli maybe limited ocean
access to 12 nautical miles so
palestinian fishermen only have enough
fish to survive for the day with nothing
left over they based their calculations
that the palestinians needed 2 279
calories to sustain the 2 million person
population so they determined they would
need 106 trucks importing goods and food
into the gaza strip however between 2007
and 2010 they only averaged 67 trucks so
what do you think of such harsh policies
for people who are shot if they try to
leave this region okay so that was a lot
um
and i don't have the study that you're
citing in front of me so i'll take your
word for it okay so the reality of the
israeli-palestinian situation is that
israel does ship
humanitarian goods into the gaza strip
literally all the time they're doing it
during the gaza war during the last gaza
war
israel is faced with the
with the reality which is that hamas
runs that area this is not an israeli
occupied territory hamas runs all
internal politics inside the gaza strip
hamas kills its opponents there's been a
civil war ongoing between hamas and the
palestinian authority which hundreds of
palestinians have been murdered inside
the gaza strip nobody covers that
because nobody cares the the endemic
poverty in the gaza strip is solely at
this point attributable to the fact that
a terrorist group has decided to spend
billions of dollars on terror weaponry
and shipping in weaponry via the sea and
smuggling it in over land if they can
although that egyptian border is locked
down pretty tight the sea is really the
only access point which is the reason
why if israel is going to restrict
access it's going to have to be from the
sea israel controls the border into
israel egypt controls the border into
egypt there's not a lot of travel over
either one of those borders although
israel presumably would like that and
there are joint israeli arab
companies that exist in for example
right like directly in the west bank
judea and samaria and directly outside
the west bank in which arabs work i mean
there are a lot of arabs who work inside
of israel for sure and palestinians
they're israeli arabs they have the same
rights as israelis there are
palestinians who don't they are governed
by the palestinian authority in the west
bank they are governed by hamas in the
gaza strip israel unfortunately is faced
with an implacable foe that decided to
spend literally hundreds well tens of
millions of dollars minimum
and shipped weapon in from iran on tens
of thousands of rockets that they
decided to fire into israeli civilian
centers let's just put it this way if
today in the united states there were 10
000 rockets fired from mexico city into
san diego the american flag would be
flying over mexico city within a week
okay that is just the way the and that
is true for virtually every country on
earth israel instead engaged in pinpoint
targeted attacks trying to kill as many
hamas members and as few civilians as
humanly possible while shipping
humanitarian goods into the gaza strip
so
the the fact that the place is run by
hamas makes it real difficult for there
to be any sort of uh serious
humanitarian effort which is i mean the
unrwa has the same problem right all the
funds for the unrwa are getting funneled
through hamas through the palestinian
authority a lot of that money is being
misdirected to to non-humanitarian goods
since it's the obligation of the israeli
government at this point to give the
goods and services to the palestinians
right wouldn't you say that it's
difficult to to place their trust in the
israeli government's hands when they're
at like an antithetical
like there's an opposition there like
well i mean typically if you're giving
foreign aid you can't is israel supposed
to just like drive the truck into the
middle of hamas area open up the back
and say people take hands like typically
when you get foreign aid you have to
work through the governing authorities
that work in a particular region if the
governing authorities are hijacking all
that stuff and then using it for
alternative goods or or selling it or
cut or using it for themselves
then what is israel supposed to do at
that point it's a serious serious
problem the humanitarian problem has to
be laid at the feet of the people who
are the actual rulers of that particular
area namely hamas which has been in
control of the gaza strip completely
there are no jews that live in the gaza
strip israel pulled completely out of
the gaza strip in 2005. it was a massive
mistake in my view they pulled out they
left no military personnel inside gaza
proper they solidified that border and
hamas has spent the last
15 years having zero elections just like
the palestinian authorities spent the
last 15 years having zero elections and
terrorizing its own
people this will be the this would be
the last question just letting everyone
know
hey ben uh really nice to talk to you
tonight um my question is about abortion
so usually when i talk about that with
other you know folks
either the approach is
from a religious religious standpoint or
trying to apply science to it
so but never seen like a
kind of like a you know happy medium
between the two so are you optimistic
that
there's gonna be i don't know
a resolution to that issue that up to
that approach maybe from a religious
perspective also with some times in it
um so i think that the possibility of a
resolution uh is going to be more
incremental than anything else and it's
happening in real time right you can see
the american people's opinions on
abortion have shifted pretty markedly
toward the pro-life position now to get
all the way to the full pro-life
position that i hold which essentially
is that from conception this is when
life begins it's going to take more work
it's going to take more education and
it's going to take a ground shift in the
way that americans tend to think about
these issues but as people see with more
clarity into the womb itself as people
see the biology more clearly they're
beginning to to become less and less
warm toward abortion like the actual
number of abortions in the united states
has dropped now to its lowest levels
since actually roe v wade and that is in
large part due
[Applause]
in large part due to the educational
efforts of a wide variety of groups it's
due to 40 ultrasounds it's true to the
ability it's due to the ability to see
more of the human biology and as people
understand that biology better they're
going to be more pro-life thank you guys
for waiting for two years and i'm so
glad that i came it's great to see you
[Applause]